President Clinton, Mr. Speaker, distinguished members of the Senate and the House, ladies and gentlemen.
There's one regret I've had throughout my life,...
...that I never became the heavyweight boxing champion of the world.
I would like my friend, Evander Holyfield, to know that today...
...I feel like the heavyweight boxing champion of the world.
It has been my great privilege to serve a people whose bondage to an inhuman system...
...evoked the solidarity of all those who love freedom and justice.
A people whose triumph over the divisions of racist doctrine has given new life...
...to humanity's hope for a world without hatred and discrimination.
I am conscious that in bestowing the Congressional Gold Medal upon me,...
...you are evoking these bonds between our nation and paying tribute...
...to the whole South African nation for its achievement in realizing our shared ideal.
It is in that spirit that I humbly accept the award, aware at the same time of the great honor...
...you do me by using me as the vehicle of a unique distinction...
...conferred by this hallowed institution of American democracy.
As one who has dedicated his life to the pursuit of unity,...
...I am moved by the consensus in your nation's regard for the achievements of my people.
And I feel great pride in the fact that to the few citizens of other countries...
...who have received this high honor, the name of an African is now added.